how do you feel now that you've you know
sort of immortalized rick james just
before he died
man all right that was real weird
as a matter of fact you know i never
talked about this i talked to him
maybe uh
two weeks before he died was the last
time i'd spoken with him right right
when we we was talking about doing a
movie really yeah he had written his
book well he had to be thrilled he
wouldn't know the thing was right when
the movie right when he was getting
ready make the deal
he had second thoughts like we had
conversations like there's certain
elements of my life that i don't want to
handle
i want to handle delicately
so what did he want to handle delicately
well i don't i didn't know it so it was
like this whole thing we did a
conference call and i was uh i'm not
gonna lie i was mad like man cause he
was right we was about to close the deal
but then it turned out and this was kind
of it was kind of deep he was he was
worried about what his kids would think
and i'm thinking maybe he was worried
about his legacy like you know what i'm
saying the one skit it's really funny
charmer fan
[Applause]
[ __ ]
will you continue doing it uh nah we
don't i don't run the characters into
the ground
maybe something like a tribute sketch
you got to do it yeah maybe something
like that yeah but it was like
for months after that it almost drove me
insane i walk around people i make james
[ __ ] i don't know how you do this thing
thing by the way what do i do i hide i
said you come out one time you stuck
your toe out of limousine and was
surrounded i didn't know how they knew
he was in the car
so do you get to hang out with eddie
murphy because you're hanging out with
his brother oh yeah i mean i've been to
his house and stuff yeah that's some
house huh yeah he's he's done quite well
for himself yeah eddie murphy's one of
the best stand-ups but then he stopped
doing it yeah man you know
see that's the thing
most of the people who are really good
at standard stop doing it and it's like
well is this something that happens that
you know i don't know i'll find out
you're going to stop i'm doing it like
with a whole new attitude the first
thing is it's like change now because
because i'm famous it's almost like
different doing it you know i come on
stage for the first five minutes people
just take your picture and they just
can't believe you there and then like it
just takes a it just takes a while to
actually be doing standard whereas
coming up through the years you're
usually just like this anonymous guy
that's got to win the crowd over you've
already won them over yeah now it's like
they've bought into it wholesale
so it's you know what i mean it's kind
of nice it's not different it's much
different it's interesting because i
remember in that uh jerry seinfeld film
he walks on stage and gets a standing
ovation he hasn't said a word right yeah
yeah exactly but it's like what you know
it was time felt so it's almost like he
just flew across the land like some
lindbergh like i don't i mean i'm not a
stamp community but i would think that
would be preferable to go out there and
have the crowd love you already then
having to warm up a full roof it would
seem that way but when you got the goods
in your pocket it's something fun
knowing
these guys have no idea what i'm going
to say or what i'm going to do right i
can't i can hand my way and now it's
like they have an expectation you're
better you look at that and they all
like come on baby do that
do do uh rick james do tyrone bingham's
do the thing from tv and it's like i
don't want to do that